alors maintenant chez vous vous éteignez
la lumière et je réponds alors en as
t'il pas la télé c'est un mec qui me dit
quand on fait la question qui tue on
éteint la lumière mais ce qu'on doit
éteindre la télé non en est un que la
lumière laurent est ici aussi
voilà c'est chaud là où tu nous lis
hernandez
serez-vous encore entraîneur du psg la
saison prochaine
jusqu'à preuve du contraire oui même si
vous perdez tous les matches qui
viennent là non je ne je ne souhaite pas
perdre et je pense qu'on ne perdra pas
tous les matches qui restent très on va
en gagner on va remonter on va on va se
situer dans une position qui sera un peu
plus honorable pour le parlement et pour
tous ceux qui aiment le pas récemment
merci on rallume robert louis dreyfus
alors dans cette affaire est ce que
finalement vous ai pas le sentiment
d'être un peu un gosse de riche qui
s'est fait plumer par l'om n'embauchent
que gosse de riche je l'étais moi c'est
pas là j'ai jamais des parents m'ont
jamais d'argent alors donc je vais pas
de problème là dessus de cette fumée non
parce qu'il ya déjà tout même à une
valeur et puis un plaisir donc savourer
ce plaisir
vous regrettez pas non pas du tout
c'était à refaire je referais je ferai
peut-être moins d'erreurs parce que
j'aurais appris quelque chose
bon allez
[Applaudissements]
didier deschamps quand je vais jouer
avec la juve
vous avez été entendu par un juge
d'instruction turinois pour des
problèmes de busage de dopage maison de
créatine qu'en est il exactement
j'ai été confrontée trois fois oui c'est
vrai à un juge d'instruction qui avant
même de poser des questions étaient
persuadés que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilisait le p o
donc c'est très difficile de
de faire face à de tel personnage la
créatine aussi c'est vrai qu'elle est
utilisée elle autorisée dans ces pays
certains pays dans d'autres noms j'en ai
pris pendant une certaine période après
j'ai arrêté je pense pas que ce soit un
produit nocif même si certains
spécialistes le disent mais le dopage en
règle générale et je pense qu'il y en a
dans le sport dans le football j'ai pas
été confronté parce que je pense
sincèrement je vois pas l'utilité
je crois pas que le dopage quand même
produit peut d'un
la joueur bidon de faire un super joueur
mais ça jamais fait tirer dans les
lucarnes je vois pas trop l'utilité ça
peut faire courir plus vite ça peut être
plus résistants mais il ya le ballon et
le balancer méfier il faut savoir le
diriger donc des matchs très souvent
même temps la répétition évidemment
qu'on a des aides
niveau pharmaceutiques pour aider à
récupérer mais ce juge là est partie du
principe moi c'est ce qui m'a dit enfin
d'interrogatoire il me dit je voudrais
arriver à faire une loi que le
footballeur ci prend un produit une
vitamine c peut importe où on est
enrhumé ou qui prend quelque chose la
semaine à voir le match il ne puisse pas
jouer un match
ouais il y aurait plus beaucoup de
football à la télé ça va bien merci de
votre sincérité l'innovation la question
qui tue sérieusement est-ce que vous
pensez que en étant parti dans les
conditions qu'on connaît en revenant en
vous faisant élire
est-ce que vous pensez que vous aidez la
politique
en agissant de la sorte mais moi je je
ne cherche pas à aider la politique je
cherche à aider la ville dans laquelle
je travaille depuis tant d'années a
progressé à aller de l'avant
j'essaye d'aider les levalloisiens moi
j'ai fais de la politique pour aider les
autres pour servir uniquement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
besoin de faire la politique
je suis né dans une famille où on avait
tout ce qu'il fallait
il y avait une affaire il y avait tout
ce qu'il fallait je n'avais vraiment pas
besoin de politiques pour gagner de
l'argent comme certains voudraient le
laissez dire laissé entendre moi j'ai
fait la politique vraiment par
conviction et je continue à faire de la
police nient toujours ici j'ai goûté
vous et finalement pour levallois s'est
pas le type à votre intérêt personnel
c'est pour la ville assad et ça l'a
toujours été et ça continuera à l'être
et mon épouse aussi et votre action
votre tour votre élection pour l'image
de la politique des hommes politiques
pro 6 est bénéfique
vous savez je sais pas si l'image des
hommes politiques est aussi bénéfique
pour moi en tout cas je marche je me
rends compte d'une chose c'est que sans
investiture je suis élu d'autres avec
les investitures de tous les partis ne
sont pas élus très bien on rallume
michel rocard
euh vous avez jamais été président si
c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil une seule chose
mettre mon mandat en balance sur un
mauvais résultat aux élections
européennes ouais pour me faire jeter
sur hazard par mauvaise foi et raté par
l'investiture
c'est ma faute technique vous avez perdu
les européennes vous n'auriez pas dû
partir finalement besoin du reste et oui
vous auriez rêvé et un an et demi avant
reprocher à laurent fabius de n'avoir
pas fait ce que tous les grands
dirigeants européens font s'ils ont
perdu on s'en va je fais partie de cette
race est aussi ma dignité
je suis partie sur une faute tactique
mais au moins dans la dignité
alors merci est ce que vous croyez pas
ivan levaï quand même que la promiscuité
des grands c'est à dire la fréquentation
que vous aviez de mitterrand vous a
amené certaines fois avoir un jugement
mois objectif que celui qu'on était en
droit d'attendre de quelqu'un d'aussi
écouté que vous non moi j'ai pas peur de
la connivence des journalistes et des
hommes politiques
il ya une chose que je redoute c'est la
malhonnêteté
or il ya des hommes politiques qui sont
malhonnêtes avec des journalistes des
journalistes qui sont malhonnêtes avec
des hommes politiques c'est tout chacun
chez soi lui il est élu vous vous ne
l'êtes pas
on ne se doit rien moi je ne dois rien
invité à la che comme ça tout ça vous ne
venez pas être plus sympas avec
mitterrand qui si vous n'aviez pas été
invité non ça permet de voir ce qu'il y
a ceux qui demeurent d'humanité vrai
chez les hommes que vous rencontrez et
je fume
oui est ce que vous étiez au courant de
l'existence de ari boulogne que nous
avons reçu ici
le fils d'alain delon et de nico qui est
né en 68 gentil à la période où vous
avez rencontré de long est ce que vous
connaissez sur l'existence ou avant que
quand j'ai rencontré alain oui je
connais très bien son existence
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas son fils et
quel cd pointé au studio en disant voilà
ton fils oui et vous pensez que c'est
passé par oui ou par non nous les noms
sont apparus aux parents c'est vous
dites donc vous êtes au courant de
l'existence d'un litre est rien je vous
dit ce n'est pas le fils d'alain delon
voilà je dis ce qui était vrai c'était
pas maintenant si vous pouvez pour
prouver le contraire
maintenant je pouvais rien du tout je me
demande pourquoi vous l'aimez bien j'ai
de la tendresse pour lui une certaine
compassion pour ce que la vie qu'il a
eue oui vous avez vu tout petit je ne
pense pas sur le fils d'alain delon
mais attendez j'étais pas là ce moment
là ce soir là non
non avant fume jean christophe
mitterrand
vous avez quoi à dire votre père ce soir
offre
que je pense beaucoup à lui que je laime
et que je regrette qu'on soit quand
j'étais jeune à peu raté merci aura lui
à méthane
eric zemmour
comment vous l'auteur des rats de garde
avec patrick poivre d'arvor qui est un
ouvrage sur la presse people et des
paparazzi comment vous pouvez dans votre
bouquin parler du suicide de laurence la
fille aînée des chirac qui est
anorexique et qui est une sorte d'
enfant caché du couple est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est bien pour le suicide
de laurence bernadette elle même en
parle donc sa mère et deuxièmement je
faisais un portrait de chirac s'était
pas un livre théorique politique
c'était un portrait de l'homme je
voulais faire un roman l'espèce de roman
vrai de jacques chirac comme un
personnage romanesque et donc j'avais
besoin de montrer
toutes les facettes de ce type et
justement pour expliquer ce que vous
avez remarqué tout à l'heure c'est à
dire qu'il sait que le bonheur n'existe
pas et que c'est un type profondément
malheureux je pense que le drame que vit
sa fille
fais partie de ceux de ce malheur profit
vous savez je raconte aussi une scène
quand pasqua
vous savez quand elle se suicide elle
est à l'hôpital et le premier le premier
à venir
c'est pasqua alors qu'ils sont en guerre
politique et que les chinois qui sont
entaillés lors de ce moment là les
chirac selon thaïlandais qui reprennent
l'avion et les pasqua vont les veillé
toute la nuit et quand pasqua sort de
l'hôpital
pasqua dit
vraiment on peut rencontrer ce qu'on
veut à chirac mais il porte sa croix
il sait que sa fille est malade parce
qu'il a fait de la politique on rallume
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que ce
que vous racontez est vrai je crois
vraiment que ce que raconte le
gouvernement américain il faut c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que je crois que
ce que j'ai analysé et certainement
extrêmement proche de la vérité on
rallume
lucien aimé blanc vous affirmez dans
votre livre
robert broussard ne pouvait pas être
témoin de la fusillade et des
circonstances qui l'ont provoquée car il
était à ce moment précis assis à côté de
moi dans sa voiture garée à 50 mètres de
là est hors de vue de la scène grâce que
vous annoncez ah bah non je confirme
complètement
nous étions dans la voiture de
commandement depuis le matin en été en
dans le périphérique un peu plus loin à
200 mètres de l'immeuble puis lorsque le
dispositif s'est mis en branle le trio
de tête est logiquement bruxelles était
tout vole en moi au passage et puis
j'avais l'inspecteur derrière c'est
cette avancée vers la porte de
clignancourt car il avait donné des
instructions pour que la voiture de de
mesrine ne dépasse pas le feu rouge
n'est pas hors de question d'aller
allait le suivre sur le périphérique on
s'arrête pas où ils allaient puis
l'opération était homme était trop trop
trop aléatoires donc cette avancée sous
la rampe au niveau de la place jean
encore une cinquantaine cinquantaine de
mètres à peu près on voyait rien et à ce
moment là la radio
le camion a fait savoir à monsieur
broussard qu'il était en place et que la
bm de mesrine était derrière
alors il a donné l'ordre d'intervention
il a dit intervenez les gens intervenez
les gars vous allez j ai gac enfin il a
donné lors d'une intervention à ce
moment là les rafales rus kat et des
rafales sèche courtes dont il venait de
sortir de la voiture et s'est précipité
sur la porte de clignancourt pour
rejoindre ses effectifs et mesrine et
aimant puisqu'il y avait pas ya pas eu
de riposte au coup par coup
y a pas eu de bruit de grenade puisque
vous savez qu'il avait des grenades dans
la voiture et moi je me suis je n'ai
suivi tout tout à fait tranquillement je
dois avouer je savais que c'était fini
je me suis pas précipité c'était lui qui
était responsable de ce dispositif
donc ce que vous affirmez aujourd'hui
lucien aimé blanc sait que le
commissaire broussard ne peut pas savoir
si des sommations ont été faites pas
plus que moyen mesrine a essayé
d'attraper des grenades offensives qui
était à l'inter de sa portière ou sous
son siège tout ce qu'il raconte c'est
pour couvrir ces mecs là je pense parce
que écouter un moment donné on était
dans la voiture il n'est pas sorti de la
voiture de commandement
et puis dans ses mémoires j'ai vu que un
moment donné au moment de la fusillade
finale il se mettait dans une
camionnette aménagée et je sais pas où
était cette camionnette aménagée mais il
aurait fallu qu'ils ont débuté il était
avec moi pour un final je le confirme
et puis c'est très bien que je dis la
vérité
il
omar raddad est ce que vous avez été
victime d'une machination
[Musique]
oui est ce que vous savez qui a monté
cette machination
non
savez pas où vous voulez pas le dire la
vérité je sais pas je veux pas causer je
peux pas faire allégeance
je peux accuser quelqu'un sans preuve
qu'on m'a fait moi je moi je ne fais pas
ça vous ne rallume
bravo à issia
les hanches irak s'est opposé à la
guerre d'irak
il peut obtenir des américains que votre
fils ait un procès équitable
si vous l'aviez en face de vous jacques
chirac lui diriez quoi monsieur le
président la vie de mon fils il est
entre vos mains et deux mois le sauver
s'ils méritent une condamnation parce
que hélas
emile et avec ce mouvement qui les
malfaiteurs s'ils méritent une
condamnation faut le faire mais pas une
condamnation à mort ni une condamnation
à vie parce que pour une mrc du rpt s'il
arrive ça mon fils aujourd'hui et peut
arriver à quelqu'un d'autre alors c'est
pas possible de laisser les américains
faire qu'est ce qu'ils veulent avec les
enfants des autres
merci aux humains
bonsoir si vous aviez le choix de
revenir sur terre une deuxième fois
est-ce que vous choisiriez d'être le
fils aîné de claude françois
oui oui parce que définitivement je suis
je suis très fier du travail accompli et
de la mémoire et de l'empreinte calais
c'est mon père donc oui voilà on
s'appelle
pourquoi votre version ska la bonne
parce que j'avance en preuve
ce que j'avance des preuves et ça c'est
une c'est une première tout le monde est
parti dans des théories là vous avez des
documents vous avez la cassette et
surtout j'ai pu prouver que billy sol
était sont utilisés et une fois que vous
prouver que billy sol est vraiment le un
conseiller johnson vous pouvez le croire
et puis j'ai entendu j'ai entendu cette
cassette enregistrée en 71 ou clips
carter explique line and johnson a donné
l'ordre d'abattre kennedy franchement
qu'est ce que vous connaissez au cheval
j'ai personnellement cheval s'appelle
auteuil et alors je lui murmure tous les
jours à l'oreille vim
titov
comment va votre frère laurent c'est un
petit peu difficile
ça va très bien il va et vient de
réaliser un making of pour le
l'enregistrement de l'album d'iam
bientôt sortir il sait bien on a
commencé l'écriture d'un film qu'on doit
écrire qu'il va réaliser
il va réaliser un court métrage aussi et
il a pris trois kilos tout va bien
finalement très bien
tatiana golovin
êtes vous venu sur ce plateau en taxi ou
par vos propres moyens
taxis ont connu en slicks est ce que
vous pouvez dire ce soir que les états
unis ont envahi l'irak enfants dans
leurs interventions sur des faux pas il
ira se fonde sur l'argument vertu duquel
il y avait des armes de destruction
massive et un danger immédiat sur
l'avenant or il aurait dû savoir que les
preuves étaient trop faibles
plus tard on s'est aperçu qu'il n'y
avait pas d'armes de destruction massive
si ils avaient dit qu'ils ont dahir
élira quoi pour se débarrasser d'un
affreux dictateur et d'un régime
sanguinaire
ça aurait été prêt mais il n'aurait pas
pu persuader le congrès américain est
clair n'aurait pas pu persuader le
parlement britannique
talleyrand guerre pour mettre fin à
cette dictature
peut-être qu'à l'avenir et dans l'avenir
des nations unies et des états unis nous
sommes prêts à mettre fin aux dictatures
simplement parce qu'elle est 100 mineurs
est affreuse mais haas pour l'instant
non mais peut-être que le jour viendra
et en tout cas c'est le souhait que je
forme aura les mains
patrick peloux si la canicule frappe à
nouveau la france cet été
les hôpitaux peuvent ils faire face si
c'était maintenant non je le dis avec
d'autant plus d'assurance que ça a été
même reconnu par le ministre de la santé
actuelle est ce qu on pourrait se
retrouver de nouveau avec 15000 morts
oui très probablement si on ne réagit
pas vite dans l'est dans les semaines
qui viennent pour justement créer un
véritable lien entre les systèmes
sanitaires et sociaux de la ville et
l'hôpital et en cas d'attentât chimique
est ce que les hôpitaux sont prêts non
on rallume
gérard darmon on veut des détails
que s'est il passé à cannes mais rien de
rien de très inhabituel quand des gens
de cinéma se rencontrent veulent se
séduire veulent se plaire veulent faire
la fête et veulent vendre leur salade
rien de voilà c'est très agréable comme
c'est sympa hormis la caisse impact je
le sens bien je veux jouer jo il s'est
passé des trucs sexuelle gens donc c'est
la même question qu'est ce que c'était
la nouba dans ton seul et j'ai compris
j'ai bien compris mais je ne sais pas je
ne peux pas vous dire j'étais dans une
autre sphère
tu peux alors là pas d'image on rallume
ça fait des années que je vous attends
des années que je tente cette question
sophie davant
quel temps va-t-il faire demain
avec cette façon qu'on va jamais posé
merci de me la poser sur certaines des
positions énormes sur le nombre de
centres où il a fait beau parce que j'ai
mes sources
le faire beau demain assure juste demain
dimanche je faisais demain dimanche il
va faire beau à paris merci merci
beaucoup
oh
dominique wolton est ce qu'à votre avis
la télé rend con non absolument pas si
vous voulez c'est les programmes qui
peuvent être con pour le spectateur
le problème c'est la responsabilité de
ceux qui font les programmes le
spectateur et regarde ce qu'on lui offre
et je crois qu'il ya une responsabilité
du récepteur du spectateur bien
évidemment mais si un gars c't'un gars
des programmes qu'on la première
responsabilité ce sont eux qui les ont
faits merci on rallume
oh
dr chaussoy vous est il déjà arrivé
depuis de regretter ce geste
non je n'ai jamais regretté parce que
encore une fois je pense que c'était la
meilleure solution et l'allemagne est la
meilleure
la meilleure décision pour 20 cents hors
éléments
[Musique]